hey what's up party people welcome to
the honest trailer commentary for ghost
rider and ghost rider 2 aka the spirit
of vengeance uh it's just me and lon
today we're going to talk about all of
our most in-depth complicated uh nuanced
ghost rider thoughts uh and then we're
going to dive into some deleted scenes
and we'll take your comments and
questions so keep those coming in the
chat and then we'll tease you with next
week's honest trailer although since i
haven't decided which one it's going to
be maybe it'll be a double tease and
i'll screw both of them up and then end
up just telling you what it's going to
be uh or maybe we can decide as a group
that could be fun maybe uh well there's
one that i don't think is available to
view yet i was really eager
it's one of the two that we're deciding
between that i have not seen pop up in
our drive
i did not see this movie on its initial
run so i'm very over eager to see it now
that would make things easier if one of
them's not out but we'll get there at
the end that's what that's about
today i believe i believe it is now out
oh and ryan's actually reminding me next
week we've actually totally done
and
very specific choice for next week
actually right yes
it's so confusing with the show because
it's like this is when i'm really
working on like the next week's one and
then i have to be like okay
ghostwriter what happened where by the
time we're you know because we're
writing them so like they edit them and
all the other people who make the
trailer take over
at some point here's what i remember
about my ghost riding experience uh
ghost riding the whip um i
i had fun i liked him i had a good time
the first one you're gonna you're gonna
come forward no the first part is just
terrible but in like a goofy it's a it's
a cute fun bad movie it's like um
all the bad parts of spider-man 3 strung
together i'd say the tone is like
cartoonish yeah it's over the top it's
ridiculous it's can't it's very campy
it's it's what before
every movie was a comic book movie and
before that was just the big genre
there was a feeling that hollywood had
of like
almost shame like this is a comic book
we gotta like okay it's gonna be really
crazy and goofy and there's gonna be
lots of unbelievable stuff in it so
we've gotta like
let the audience know that we know this
is dumb and childish and like kind of
neg the movie's origin right from the
start and and that first ghost rider is
definitely made i think in that spirit
of like the movie almost feels it's the
same guy mark steven johnson who did
daredevil daredevil yeah and they both
have this feeling of like kind of
right they kind of feel bad about their
origins and they're like apologizing for
it in the movie yeah and there's a lot
of uh uh winking to the camera and be
like my skull feels like it's on fire
which is like sub sub weediness although
there is lots of joss whedon stuff of
like uh he literally says well that just
happened to the camera yeah
it's it's from that era before we'd all
kind of before that trope had become
well known when people were still just
like i'm gonna do a well that's happened
not if not even a meta thing or whatever
it's just like yeah
oh no you didn't you know ghostwriter
spirit of vengeance i think is a fun
even on its own terms like falls out
insane
action movie with ghost rider in it it
could be better like given that these
guys made the cranks um it could have
been it's not as good as it's not as
good as a crank uh you can def
definitely crank crank one out before
you see ghost rider spirit of vengeance
one or two um but
i do want to live in the world where
spirit of vengeance uh you know punisher
war zone throw dread in there uh where
though that became the template for
comic book movies i think it fits in
with those not dread is pushing it but i
think
it's kind of bla also blade way pushing
it this is like a d level blade but it's
in the same
conversation and tone there was there
was this moment i think i've talked
about this before there was this moment
in like the late 90s early aughts where
it's like comic book movies could kind
of go one of two ways there's like the
really impressionistic
crazy ones where they kind of mash up
the comic book world in a movie world
and create something weird and like new
and it's almost like even the rainy
spider-mans are kind of in that vibe and
then there's the like smooth out all the
rough edges and make it like palatable
like a mainstream action tentpole movie
like the mcu and the singer x-men
franchise and like that kind of became
the
standard so well that became the third
strand of the the nolan of it all and
it's like no these are actually for
adults and not children these are grown
up philosophical ponderous things and i
feel like every once in a while we get a
comic book movie that is made in that
impressionistic style like most recently
i feel like it was venom let there be
carnage
i liked it because it's just like it
doesn't feel like a venom comic book it
doesn't feel like a superhero movie it's
just his own weird crazy thing that
doesn't bother to like have a realistic
world and i thought it was fun but i
think if you prefer the
you know mcu house style
this kind of violates that and spirit of
engines doesn't feel like it's that kind
of serious treatment of the character
like we said for spirit of vengeance it
doesn't uh reach like full crank levels
but you can see the potential of these
directors plus if they had really taken
the breaks off of nick cage that you
would have had i think a great movie on
your hands the the seeds of a really
great uh action uh comic book movie are
in this film but they're not fully
blossomed and they are letting cage go
even bigger than he was going in the
first ghost rider like we are
approaching that real uh operatic you
know peak cage yes there are a few
moments where he really gets to that
cage level that you want to see when
you're watching a nick cage action comic
book movie totally so that's when you
want to take take the blocks off you
know
john bainbridge asks what superhero
should cage do next i think he should
just still be ghost rider i think that
the uh
the potential is there and people would
love it like who wouldn't be
who wouldn't like to see him roll back
in
in a climactic scene you can even keep
him on disney plus you know he doesn't
have to be in the next avengers movie
but he'd be a great new street level
hero and i don't know he looks the same
to me he still got the same energy i
think he could totally uh step into the
boots and jacket once again
uh i would love to see him as like a
villa i feel like he's like in the
perfect place to play like one of these
big iconic like comic book movie
villains like the mcu needs it's victor
von doom and like i don't think you
could do anything better cage
no
really sounds amazing to me yeah
uh just sipping a martini glass full of
jelly beans there you go that's his one
requirement i mean or just let him do
superman it's finally time cavill's done
this is now now is the moment yeah now's
the time
all right uh by earth's yellow sun he
could be a little older he'd still be
super strong it's not like superman ages
out
all right that's the time for
us to watch ghost rider one and two
because we'll have so much more to say
uh as we stop and start let's roll it
[Music]
from marvel back in their tryhard phase
the filmmaker responsible for some of
the best bad moments in superhero cinema
the guys who cranked out some of the
puzzles
i just like to say if somebody can dig
this up uh i
i hope it still lives somewhere on the
internet if not i might believe it does
okay avalon and i reenacting the the
daredevil playground scene i think it is
still out there okay good i um
that and the catwoman basketball center
i feel like our pandemic has really
hindered our on-screen chemistry yeah
really yeah
we had a little running we were doing
more of like honest recreations for a
little a moment there it was it was a
little labor intensive for the the
actual output
let us know in the chat uh what what we
should count but let's just say a
trifecta what we should cap off right i
think honest action is what we were
calling those well there was honest
actually a different thing i think it
was just on a scene honestly yeah where
it would be like spencer i recreate
great moments from you know
without all those fancy cuts and editing
and colors what was the other one
catwoman right
basketball scene yeah the catwoman
basketball scene the daredevil
playground see we could use one more
once once we're reunited post pandemic
maybe one more yeah let us know all
right uh keep playing movies since they
cranked out both cranks
and the screenwriting equivalent of
herpes comes to films that feel like
going on a 48-hour coke bender with nick
cage and by that i mean they're a bad
idea but still pretty fun
the angel
i could feel him
ghostwriter and ghostwriter spirit of
vengeance
only one man is unique
the cosmology here very confusing in the
second one the first one okay it's
basically they don't really get into it
it's like he the devil tricked him in
deciding this deal and now he's gotta
like do jobs for the deaf okay okay fair
enough i could i could dig that the
second one is like
changes the origin we retcon the peter
fonda devil in favor of the uh kieran
hines devil
but then it adds this whole like origin
story for the ghost rider where he was
an angel that they took to hell yeah
being an
angel an angel went crazy which is a
weird that's already just like wait
angels have like brains that can go
crazy like why would that why would that
be but uh
but yeah like that then so it's like so
the devil is just like partnered with
this other demon that went crazy like
wait hang on and it never really unpacks
it and then the the power of the crazy
angel goes to the little boy who's the
half son of satan oh there's so much
with children satan's constantly getting
knocking ladies up and having these kids
all over the place it's very it's very
messy satan is a dead beat dad in this
universe um and then he like gives him
his power and then chooses to barf it
back into nick cage at the end instead
of using it we'll get to this one oh
weird it's so weird and like never like
why did you make it complicated at all
why why not just make it like i need
that boy i'm the devil okay that's it
that's all you no questions no follow-up
questions
uh all right keep playing one man is
uniquely qualified to be the ghost
writer nick cage cause this actor's
already been an outcast who melts his
face off like a wicker man trapped
between worlds this army of one will
drive angry seeking justice when it gets
dark he'll kick ass with his kill chains
as a prisoner of the ghost land because
this lord of war is running with the
devil and he's got a score to settle
holy crap he makes a lot of movies it's
almost inconceivable what a pig or a
national treasure depending on how you
look at it
props to uh our editor kevin who had
this that idea to to intercut
this section with his actual films um
and then uh a uh question from fj
pretzel lord of war is in the movie
montage are you guys saying that it's a
bad movie i think it's quite good and
intelligent no
we got pig in there national treasure
face off like there's lots of movies
that we were just saying he makes a lot
of movies not that they're all bad i
don't yeah saying you could construct
paragraphs about his films using only
the titles from his other films is his
only point it's also nice we can sort of
tease nick cage for making all of these
directive video titles safely because it
was just for the money we know it was
just for the money he who went broke and
he needed some cash it's not it's not
like it you know we're gonna in three
years we're going to hear news it's
going to be like oh we shouldn't be yeah
those skulls don't pay those dinosaur
skulls don't pay for themselves um right
especially when they're honestly
some of them aren't so bad he's directed
to vod nicholas cage films i've seen a
few that i think hold up all right yeah
he doesn't uh usually doesn't hold back
um i wanted to see that one about him
like on the as like the animal trainer
with the tiger on the primal i think
that that one wasn't that one that's a
shame
uh all right let's let's keep going grow
up with johnny
cough aka movie speak for dying of
cancer
he'll make a deal with the devil to
prolong his life for about one afternoon
[Applause]
stricken with grief teenage johnny will
ghost his sweetheart leaving her to grow
into a reporter with a 10-year age
difference and now must become the ghost
rider a demon with the powers of riding
a motorcycle which she could already do
and scaring people to death with eye
contact which again nick cage could
already do
again
again like just of its era is like
ghost rider gets his powers um
nebula says they are uh and they're like
how do we show that he's like still a
superhero and as soon as he gets his
powers he's like
i need to i hear a mugging i'm gonna go
stop a mugging that like runs over to
save rebel wilson from getting held up
you know in a back alley because i just
i think some executive is like it's a
superhero you need to you need to go
save a girl from a from a crook there
was a while there where every big
superhero movie they it felt like that
was like they had to work in
contractually there had to be like a
scene where they like stop whatever the
plot of the movie is to like stop street
crime where it was like that's what
people expect you know like that yeah it
was still like it was a genre with like
expectations it was like this is what
these movies are it's like an alley and
then the brother getting mugged and then
the hero swoops in
and he's like stop at you and like take
something you know like that but it's
such a standout in this one because like
it's never assumed that he's going to go
fight crime
or like could be like a street level
patrol man with what literally works for
the devil he works for the devil uh but
he eventually says that at the very end
of the first one that he's going to use
the powers that the devil gave him to
fight the devil uh
without considering that the devil could
just remove the powers hey tucker um
yeah it's it doesn't make oh that that
stuff doesn't really make any sense and
it's just it's weird because the first
movie leads so clearly into what they
were thinking the sequel would be which
is now ghostwriter is going to become
like a savior of humanity using his
devil powers to fight the devil but his
devil powers are like sending evil
people to hell which you'd think would
only help the devil
yeah it's hard to see how that would
work but they set that up and then the
next movie not only doesn't really do
that at all but like really retcons the
whole thing it's like no no he now he's
back to hating being the ghost rider and
he's desperate to get rid of it not like
he's keeping the powers on yeah they
turn him in the hulk in the second one
he's just like on the run from his own
flaming head um eva mendes never to be
spoken up again who has a very very
thankless also like the stock female
character in an early
2000s um comic book movie is just to
like stand there and look hot and swoon
over the hero like that is all she gets
to do it's really not i mean the whole
the whole art her her whole appearance
in ghost writer one is basically built
around like ava mendes can't get a date
like that's the whole like guys are not
into her
and she's still hung up on this dude she
dated briefly and like a teenager yeah
and uh she's just like hapless and like
hopeless in love and it's like
eva mendes that's who you casted for
this role like that's
it's like we it's so bizarre because
it's like
i mean she'd probably be doing all right
she's alive she's on tv
she's even mendez she's a reporter
covering stuntmen
i love how popular stunt shows are in
the in the ghostwriter universe oh yeah
he's killing an arena he's he's in a
like rock band tour but he's in like
what kings of leon drives around this
country and
to do like back to yards like hot rod
style stunt shows yeah yeah it's weird
um good for him
all right keep playing making it work
follow up the campy original with an
edgelord reboot in ghost rider spirit of
vengeance where they change his look
supporting cast and origin story because
just shut up and embrace the chaos okay
fire piss
he made a deal with the devil now in the
follow-up he'll have an even worse idea
and make a deal with a priest to bring
him a young boy bring us the boy
in a sequel that abandons all restraint
and just gives the people what they want
a skull monster barfing fire bullets
into a goon's face
full of high octane visuals that almost
overcome the moment when the ghost rider
scold you for pirating movies you did
something you wouldn't want the writer
to see a white lie an illegal download
you wouldn't download a crane oh wait
you would
uh pause first of all that part's
awesome when he turns
i guess like and they even make fun of
the this in the movie um which seems
very marvel uh like modern day marvel of
like well when you get on an elevator
like is that what you're riding can you
turn that like didn't they reuse that in
thor and stuff oh interesting
um but yeah uh
yeah yeah this one introduced the second
one introduces the idea that whatever
any
machine or vehicle or whatever
once he's operating it it becomes it
gets his like hellish makeover yeah
that's the thing i don't think that's
got in the final script but i was very i
was very taken with the rider very
aesthetically focused like it's at the
moment the rider comes into our world
his first thought is well i got to redo
my look i gotta like the jacket needs
some customization i gotta make the bike
look hell it's gotta have a skull on it
he's he's like very into the brand but i
figured that had that happened
automatically like it just you know just
it does but it's he's he's the spirit
he's making it happen
he has magic hell powers and he's like
hang on
gotta gotta do the bike upgrade first
once we'll do the magic bike upgrade
then we'll move on to like fighting
it also just does it does date it so
specifically that that it was that
moment of complete panic in hollywood
that like music had been you know free
for a while quote-unquote and like
movies were next and oh boy did they
have to stop people from downloading the
movies uh they were so so freaked out it
was it was this moment where it's hard
to believe now because like streaming
became the thing and like
torrenting i don't like obviously
there's still a segment of the internet
that's doing it but i like there was a
panic for a moment that everybody was
just going to figure out bittorrent and
ever stop paying for entertainment like
ever again yeah and i know some of you
still don't and uh hey you dude
there's a pocket of people out there
still doing it i know that but like it
didn't become as dominant as i think
hollywood feared a lot of people also
just got natural yeah but there were
like a lot of there's some kind of pop
culture stuff like that there was like
the
stop all the downloading message and
then they they showed a picture of jerry
springer i think when they were talking
about the devil or like the yeah
this was 2011. this was a cultural
moment where we were like
you know oh that trash television like
jerry springer that garbage i only watch
ghost rider poisoning uh discourse you
know
yeah get him get him ghost rider i guess
it was still it was only like twitter
was only three or four years old at that
point it wasn't old enough to poison our
discourse yet so we were still blaming
jerry springer so cute
okay uh let's keep going
speed through two early comic book films
that would be pretty forgettable if it
weren't for the cage of it all as nick
brings a grab bag of random quirks to
johnny blaze like an elvis accent that
disappears after the first film you know
i watch a lot of tv and you do a really
good job only drinking straight from the
container
you know no time
in which case martini glass
while off camera he was bringing the
weird
makeup we got to talk about that because
it's so specific like if it was one
scene i'd be like he just was on set and
was like bring me some jelly beans that
are martini but it's multiple look like
they this was in the script this was
part of the plan
this was like a round on multiple days
why what is what why well not a good way
we know he's sober right he like well i
don't know about nick cage but we know
that the character
right yeah um
and uh like i i to me it's like that's
the one indulgence he'll allow himself
like he's such a focused you know
principled man who who only thinks about
his next stunt
so that's the only way he headlines is
that and and 1930s uh animation yeah the
guy whose only vice is jelly bean i'm
not even against that i okay but it's
just if you were always eating jelly
beans a martini glass clearly is the
least effective delivery system just get
a big like mason jar full of them that's
the way it makes you feel you can't sip
a mason jar i i think it'd be easier
actually to sip
a martini glass full of jelly beans and
get the right amount which is like you
know four or five jelly beans it feels
like very if you're glasses you're
getting you're getting dumped on you
know i feel like i i martinez is the
worst possible container i think he's
honestly jelly bean iron it does she
just it just sound off in the comments
what is the best thing to drink
jellyfish if you're gonna be drinking
jelly beans if you're like that's your
cocktail what kind of container would
you put your jelly beans in yeah let us
know yeah let us know maybe did you
notice by the way again very
aesthetically minded only eats red and
yellow colored jelly beans yeah
it's not a rainbow that's like donald
logue's job when he's done polishing the
bikes just to pick out
already
only or ozzy doesn't go on stage that
night yeah okay let's keep playing
while off camera he was bringing the
weird by doing his own makeup sewing
totems into the lining of his jacket and
then i would sew in bits of uh egyptian
artifacts that were thousands of years
old into my costume and just generally
freaking out at all times for our
entertainment
that's the best one
[Music]
you can tell he this is the character he
loves he wanted to be johnny blaze he
was into ghost rider he's like one of
the driving forces for why this movie
happens because i'm sure marvel would
have even at this time would have rather
done other characters but you got a star
who really wants to be johnny blaze
ghost rider and and you go with it i
think i that's why i think he's the
perfect fit i wouldn't recast
no i don't why would you i mean i don't
come out of that multiverse i don't i
don't think you need to i mean they did
they had another they had a team they
have one agency yeah yeah but it's a
different
notably it's the other i forget the
character's name it's not johnny blaze
it's the other guy who becomes ghost
writer right i believe robbie ray robbie
reyes thank you uh so you could have
both there's no reason not to have both
those riders hundred percent
um there was a uh good question uh uh
james bunt movie fight method acting
versus nouveau shamanic uh which is nick
cage's uh sure self-described acting
style um who wouldn't go with nouveau i
know right who's our representative for
method acting is it jared leto because
in that case i think everybody's going
with kate yeah yeah it's it's a it's
kind of a knockout and he's cages
described nouveau shamanic is like it's
just it's like something he came up with
after reading a book that was like
acting is channeling the same
energies and and outlet culturally as
like the shamans did uh you know
in pre-industrial times of
you know channeling other spirits and
beings and yeah
he makes a lot of sense no i i
interviewed him about this once uh for
that movie frozen ground with john
cusack and he was saying that on stage
we accept bigger than realistic acting
like we just kind of in a musical or
whatever you'd be like oh yeah well
that's that's not how i would act in
this scenario but i also wouldn't be
singing and dancing i also wouldn't be
on a broadway stage so i give myself
over to it and it's about the effect
that it has not about the realism and
he's like why can't that be in cinema do
we just locked into this notion that
cinema means realism and it's like it
doesn't have to
yeah yeah well there you go uh a nouveau
shamanic wins it's a knockout no one
will even make it i mean like listen
there are actors who go who'd use the
method silence and give like if we're
putting daniel day lewis that there will
be blood up against him like well now
you've got a movie fight you know but
there are a lot of examples of method
actors that i think easily are topped by
yeah uh nikolai chimes and he's
channeling his death metal persona and
yeah this basically is a character from
like guar or something like that he's
just you could totally throw him on
stage it's a it's a demon biker with a
flaming skull head of course yes that's
when you tell me your death metal person
yeah
uh all right let's keep going
but the cage won't rage alone there's a
whole cast carefully selected by the
directors for their authentic
europeanness i mean like all europeans
they just they have an accent right it's
over there in the europe it's the wrong
like idris elba
a french priest so stereotypical we were
going to make a joke like
i love it to drinks of wine but that's
more or less his actual dialogue
has the narrator from the big lebowski
doing the kind of authentic portrayal of
the american west that he stands for
jane campion could never rebel wilson
huh that's random a one division fan
theory video's worth of mephisto's
played by one actor who has to be in
this movie because his deal with the
devil was up and one actor who has to be
in this movie for his deal with the
devil to get started plus a new metal
band's worth of unthreatening pale demon
boys look out ghost rider it's puddle
guy why dreadlocks rockabilly twilight
and the personification of mold
i think that's one place where they
really really whiffed and was a uh an
area where they could have done
something cool is with the the various
uh demons yeah did you not take them
down the first movie because they're
doing like the elemental thing it's it's
sort of this weirdly like reverse avatar
like yes the fire nation is the good guy
fighting the air guy the water guy and
the earth guy
it occurred to me halfway through it's
like it's like if zuko was the hero of
avatars
well he is an alleged in some ways but i
i think that uh
that um
and by that i mean the m night shyamalan
version right oh i mean like
not that zuko doesn't end up in a heroic
play he was the protagonist yeah
they really were not ready to
do that um
uh visually the puddle man is
particularly
not scary he's just wet i do i will say
i will distinguish again between one and
two like the bad guys in one look real
rough
old guy in two they kind of pull it out
like well that kind of pulls up but they
did some weird things
like they picked a character from the
comics blackout who can you know as they
as his name implies you know black out
the area around you and like kept that
power set but added on mold
yeah
he can also
touch it yeah um
so if you're just gonna just create
something new or i don't know it seems
like trying to have it both ways and and
whiffing on both i mean i at this point
i feel like if you were doing an mcu
ghost rider like it's gonna join the
rest of the universe you'd wanna put
authentic comic book bad guys in there
to bring that exciting comics to the mcu
but in this it's a one-off anyway like
who cares just make up a villain for
your that suits your movie yeah
um all right let's keep going heard to
the bad old times 2000's comic book
movies before iron man made them cool
and no one prestiged the sh out of
everything even though real fans know
these are some of the most true to
comics films ever made not because
they're accurate because they're loud
fun and barely makes sense comics are
mostly dumb that's why we love them my
name is
all right starring
daredevil what it makes more sense for
him than a blind lawyer blazing anime to
deal with the devil girls one eva
low gang
soul man
demonic and knuckles the conjuring the
devil made me do it with him hellboy
decay hole
dembledor
praden
and the least realistic
praden really did not get enough to do i
love um that's not david carradine he
was the first bear christopher lopez
yeah um he cast him as like the leader
of a secretive order of of monks and
like all he does is is get wrecked by
mold guy
i i figured he was gonna be revealed as
like he's the true villain like yeah if
you bring in a guy with that level of
genre prestige i'm assuming it's because
there's some third act surprise uh so
imagine my disappointment your superior
double surprise there is not at all
surprises there is no surprise he's just
burped right away yeah and he dies yeah
yeah what a shame and not make powers or
anything it doesn't do nothing yeah
there could be more than one apparently
all right keep going flaming skull demon
biker i think i should walk you to your
car you're purty and all but why don't
you just go back to wherever it is you
came from you think i'm pretty right
just constant rejection for eva messages
in 60 seconds report star reporter
okay why does roxanne bring a magic
eight ball on a date yeah will it be
she might be insane
that might be part yeah i mean
that's the only reasonable conclusion
because she's it's not a big purse that
she has
that's a that's a weird effect two
thirds of it are taken up by a magic
eight ball we all know a gal who brings
an eight ball around with her day goes
you know
oh mr quirky thing you know it's a good
conversation that's a huge quirk
that's a big one that's like a garden
state natalie portman level four they're
like they're on the scooter and she's
taking out her eight ball she's playing
eucalyptus i play more [ __ ] yeah
signs pointy yes okay
god we gotta re-watch garden state no oh
when's that on this trailer oh my god
let's see what uh let's see what we
deleted from this one starring
that johnny blaze is so hot right now
roxanne you don't have to go on that
ghost ride
waitress elbow
priest of no nation
i'm drunk mila fuba [ __ ] boss baby hell
fast
ghost ride the chain whip
american chopper
hot ones
the unbearable weight of total excrement
vicious cycles
finish him scorpion wins flawless
victory fatality
did you know those were real
strangely wet ass
yeah man he kind of set the temperature
you know
i guess so yeah
he uh he says he worked out for five
hours a day for that shot and uh yeah he
says they're real everybody says they're
real
i've never looked like that with my
shirt off so you know yeah
i feel like there's a really uh a good
um christian version of this movie where
he gets his powers and then he just uses
them to convert people because that
would be a better way to fight the devil
then
killing other people who does have that
like he's basically an angel yeah like
so you're right there i mean a third one
where he's just an angel on earth doing
angel things is uh an easy sequel to
write yeah
stairway to heaven the movie or whatever
uh totally and uh so moving on to the
question stuff like jim one saying are
are we today missing comic book movies
like ghost rider we could just go in
have a good time without always having
to be caught up on a cinematic universe
um i mean weirdly you are entirely like
i think there's still i think aquaman
qualifies yeah
let's see what else there's a lot of
standalone dark ones like the batman i
loved but it's you know it's not a good
time necessarily but i really liked it
and there's also the streaming
like world is we're seeing so many more
you know indie comics or not marvel dc
kind of titles getting adapted so you
know like even if the movies or you're
not into the mcu and the dc eu like well
you've got the boys and you've got
invincible and you've got umbrella
academy and like lock and key and like
there's so many uh
you know you're not sort of tied to just
following these big cinematic uh
universes anymore yeah but
marvel they're full they're all in
they're all in on this stuff um yeah i
mean there's like i mean i guess like
moon knight is like the rare example of
so far you don't really need to know any
other mcu stuff it's only been one give
it time
connection to gameplay else
what were you guys doing that whole fano
situation that's crazy
uh there you go um let's see what else
we got uh mj pretzels tell us more about
what it was like speaking to nick cage
oh um i it was brief i only i got to
chat with him for maybe like i think i
got seven or eight minutes it was a
really fun day though because i got to
talk to him and then i got to talk to
john cusack and i got vanessa hudgens at
the end and they did not they told me it
was cage and cusack so i had a whole
bunch of stuff prepared they did not
tell me about vanessa hutchins so i had
to like
just come up with stuff what's your new
shamanic process right like well i mean
i heard that that movie is frozen ground
it's like this serial killer thing uh
it's based loosely based on a true story
so i got to dig into that like for real
the real characters you get to beat the
real lady and all that you know all that
stuff and then i think i feel the rest
of time with spring breakers questions
yes uh but no it was great to meet cage
super nice guy really appreciated that i
had come with like thoughtful questions
about his acting and not just like what
was it like working with x or you know
the kind of generic uh junket questions
that they usually get uh and yeah you
like played a little game it was he was
great he was it was it was exactly what
you'd want me to briefly meeting your
your movie hero to be like that's
awesome
uh james bond asks what other actors
should name their acting style like cage
has with nouveau shamanic hmm like well
yeah what other actor has like a super
idiosyncratic like like walk-in could do
like you know
the the pull-out method where he just
randomly pulls out of sentences
gerard butler let me just throw this out
gerard butler kind of started doing a
bunch of different kinds of roles in
movies but i feel like he's now he's
really like older
grizzled gerard butler has become like a
type like he moves beyond he moves
through movies like the gerard butler of
den of thieves of the gerard butler of
thieves
is the same gerard butler and i like
that
how what is that there's like eight
elements that go into a grizzled gerard
butler turn yeah i mean there's plenty
of people who play themselves or who get
typecast as a certain type of character
but he seems to have really locked into
this this sleaze ball right it's like
kind of sleazy but also sort of
anti-heroic and also like like but also
like over it like like washed up and
like you know totally cynical and bitter
alcoholic but like not a terrible guy
you know it's like it's all of these
shades it's really interesting for
anyone watching that hasn't uh seen
denim thieves um uh run don't walk to
your nearest redbox
nearest red box i i i i gotta catch up
on capture top chops on peacock now
because you folks haven't seen it yet
one of my favorite uh like low budget
like uh zany 2021 titles
uh all right we'll wrap up with this uh
pat mcgonass what's the most random
appearance by a future star in a movie
like rebel wilson in ghost rider
i had one recently with um that just
reminds me i'm pretty sure it was i was
re-watching go and melissa mccarthy
isn't go like yes you know
not not a cameo but like uh she's got a
couple seconds i think that was also
that was one of the first things i saw
timothy olympia that would make sense
he's that
questionable drug dealer at that yeah uh
i just watched battleship because i
think it's on hbo
everyone's a battleship every single
background guy with like three like as
you know it's like it's on a battleship
so there's a lot of like naval officer
number two and they're all it's like
jesse plemons and romney malik is in
there and hamish link later sneaks in
there like rihanna was the big still
like rihanna and liam neeson and
alexander skarsgard were the stars but
literally everybody in a background role
went on to become fake that's a
contender for worst movie best cast
um honestly i didn't think it was that
bad and one thing i i really admired
about it is it's not like they they went
to great lengths to actually integrate
elements of the battleship game like the
aliens you gotta have that the alien
weapons like look like the pegs
and at one point they bring up a grid oh
i know their targeting goes down yeah
they're talking right grid it's it's
like
like how can you how can you make a
battleship movie better than that you
you kind of can't you can't you could
ignore that but hey you can't ignore it
but why would you i want you to
all right i think that's enough for
today
we'll be back uh next week which we do
know what we're doing um next week um
let's see how to tease this uh
well um
it might make you twitch uh but i think
that it's actually a smooth ride down
the amazon river
um
yeah
yeah i don't know i it's hard for me i'm
struggling with this one but
uh but we'll see you then uh when we
will reveal the next episode of
australia commentaries thanks for
watching talk soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you